en esta foto de familia de la cumbre de
la unión europea celebrada en versalles
en marzo las mujeres eran claramente
minoría a pesar de tener a ursula von
der leyen como presidenta de la comisión
europea sólo 5 de los 27 gobiernos de la
unión europea están dirigidos por
mujeres y todos ellos son países del
norte del continente dinamarca estonia
lituania suecia y finlandia nunca he
pensado que se trate de mi edad o mi
género creo que se trata de las razones
por las que me comprometí con la
política y por eso pude ganarme la
confianza de los votantes con driver
mail inmediata fui la primera mujer en
ser elegida primera ministra de suecia y
sé lo que significa esto para las niñas
de hoy en nuestro país qliktech su voto
antes de ellas la británica margaret
thatcher y la alemana angela merkel
estuvieron al frente de sus países
durante décadas después de la primera
primera ministra de francia y vic geison
en
1991 elisabeth born es ahora la segunda
mujer que dirige la república pampita
wind posee por apoño fama
me gustaría recordar a la primera mujer
que ocupó este cargo de primera ministra
edith cresson y me gustaría dedicar mi
nombramiento a todas las niñas
diciéndoles vivan sus sueños nada debe
detener la lucha por el lugar de la
mujer en nuestra sociedad
y su nombramiento es un símbolo de
diversidad que los franceses aprecian su
bien su sensual y es estupendo que vaya
a ser una mujer espero que sea capaz
para qué estado está pero estoy
convencido de que el hecho de que sea
mujer cambie mucho pero creo que es
importante que las mujeres estén
representadas en todos los sectores
incluido el gobierno la composición del
nuevo gobierno francés se anunciará en
los próximos días